welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Fabien Drexler assistant professor of
history at Yale University professor
Drexler teaches Japanese history today
we talk with him about his forthcoming
book infanticide and fertility in Japan
1652 1950 welcome professor Drexler
thank you delighted to be here let's
begin talking about your book tell us a
little bit about it so the book is a
cultural history of infanticide and a
demographic history of fertility change
wrapped into one one way to think about
it is that they're there is this great
turning point that I that I identify in
the years around 1800 so in 1750 you
have a world where in large parts of
Japan people will only try to raise two
or three children and some of those
children will dies at the end of the day
they'll have less than two descendants
for a couple the way they achieve that
is through widespread infanticide mostly
by 1850 infanticide has been questioned
has been combatted has been widely
discussed and people once again now
raise four or five children per couple x
1920 they raised six kids and
infanticide is rapidly becoming
something that that is more or less
unthinkable so that's that's the the
great arc that I'm trying to describe
for the school and it is such a it's an
interesting topic and I would imagine
somewhat of a difficult one infanticide
and you've looked at many different
aspects of Japan why infanticide for
instance why write this book
um infanticide is a great window into
people's minds because the whole
practice of it which has become so
unthinkable in our society depends on
the way that people imagine themselves
in in the universe and in the way they
they understand when human life begins
what happens after death both for the
infant's you kill and perhaps your
ancestors who linger around the family
as protective spirits it relates in more
complicated ways to do the way you
imagine the nature of time the way you
define community so in that sense it's a
very attractive topic um the other
reason though why I think it's it's so
important is that demography is a great
way to understand the past in many ways
and really a colonization frontier of
knowledge there's shockingly little in
many ways we know about the demographic
past of our world and there's been a
huge amount of wonderful work over the
past two or three generations but the
things we don't know are just
astonishing once you once you
contemplate them okay and let's talk
about your methodology how did you do
your research so the research really has
has 2 major legs the first leg is the
demographic analysis of a large
collection of individual level data so I
spent many years going through libraries
and archives tracking down population
registers from the seventeenth
eighteenth and nineteenth century and
are they readily accessible some of them
are when wonderful thing about Japan is
that each municipality has at some point
in the last 50 or 60 years launched a
local history project whereby they they
wrote up the history of their town and
even for small villages these these
collections can run to 10 minutes
magnificent clothbound volumes and in
many of those they they collect
that the documents that are available
locally type them up for you publish
them and deliver them to the shelves of
the Sterling Memorial Library and this
is especially important because the
archival system of Japan for the early
modern period anyway is not especially
well developed and so only a small
fraction maybe five maybe ten percent of
the surviving village-level documents
from this period can actually be
accessed in archives all the rest is
still owned by the descendants of the
headman for instance who created these
documents in the first place and so the
only efficient way of accessing them
without going through a long dance of
gaining the trust of these individuals
it's to to find them in these
collections that said the archival
collections have been really useful for
my project as well so that's something
like a third of these population
registers are things that I've that I've
found in archives so that's the first
leg the second leg is a wonderful wealth
of different types of materials on
infanticide I say wonderful because well
it's a strange word you use maybe in
this context but as i go deeper and
deeper into this project i was just
astonished how many different kinds of
materials you can find about infanticide
so their policy proposals that villagers
might send to their Lord with ideas of
how to combat infanticide there are
pregnancy reports that peasant women had
to submit to the authorities to to
respond to to do to a surveillance
policy that tried to stamp out
infanticide but then were unexpected
things too like poems about stila for
murdered silkworms in in regions where
people kill infants without a second
thought according to the oath of the
poem or the dialogue between a louse and
the giant bird Pung of the East Asian
best Yuri whose wingspan is a thousand
leagues
they talk about infanticide they talk
about nothing but infanticide and then
finally there is a rich visual record as
well and to track down that record has
been the most adventurous exciting part
of the research process because a lot of
these materials are rather large wooden
boards that are painted with an
infanticide scene and the murderous
mother then transforms into a she-devil
or an animal so the message being you
commit infanticide you lose your
humanity and a lot of these have been
lost because they weren't considered a
great works of art but several doesn't
remain and often they are tucked away in
some chapel deep in the mountains that
might only open on to predetermined days
in the year for for airing out as they
call it and then the community gathers
in the chapel and and has a little party
were you able to visit on those days and
have access to that information or write
with the help of many people I was and
you know also get a sense of how the
descendants of people in these areas who
are now in charge of those chapels think
about those artifacts and think about
the history of infanticide one of the
most wonderful things was that I found
this one local employee of a prefectural
Museum and I went there because I knew
that they and their and their storage
had one infanticide tablet it is that
why don't you come back in three or four
days I'll get the museum car and then
I'll Drive you to all the places you
want to be driven in my prefecture and
so he you know given the list of sites I
wanted to visit he made all the phone
calls he got the car and I had this
delightful for days when for this very
generous man are tracking down these
images that in many cases you can't find
anywhere in the published record now in
sitting here listening to you the
thought strikes me particularly when you
look at the you know written registries
were the deaths tracked or was it just
births so in other words did they just
you know pretend that the death never
happened and
how does that work that's a very astute
question there's not a whole lot of
direct evidence a foreign Fanta side so
we have won diary of a man who who
mentions that he kills his own children
in three cases and a couple of other
documents where people admit that they
themselves are practicing infanticide
but on the whole we have the complaints
of people who think that infanticide is
a problem or they're sort of rather
feeble excuses of people who think that
it's not a problem and then we have the
patterns of the demographic record and
to respond more directly to your
question the population registers of the
Tokugawa period the heart of the 300
years that I span and my project only
recorded children typically the first
time the annual recording virtual
coincided with their lives so if a child
was born in December the first recording
might be in in March when the population
register was compiled if the child was
born in April it would also be in march
of the next year and so we we can't
actually literally track births with a
couple of exceptions and we don't see
these early these early childhood deaths
so part of my methodology was to back
project the pop that the population and
there's been a lot of good work that
allows us to estimate the unintended
infant mortality rates with a lot of
confidence they're rather odd fifteen
twenty percent and so if you find ten
children and the in the record this
means that you you should assume that
originally there were twelve or thirteen
children I mean put put very crudely and
so really the the victims of infanticide
are these absences that we have to track
down on the record and the visible in
all sorts of patterns patterns that
depend on the gender of the child for
for example but also the timing of the
birth and then just in the implausibly
low number of children that the people
say they've given birth
we're talking two or three children when
under the kind of conditions of life and
contraceptive technology and so on that
people had at the time it's hard to
imagine that people would have had fewer
than six or seven children without the
practice of infanticide you speak of
three different cultures of infanticide
in Japan let's talk a little bit about
that so I think one good way to
visualize those different cultures is to
look at two encounters that happened in
high weigh-ins in Japan in the early
18th century one of them was between one
of them involved a pilgrim from a part
of southern Shikoku who was going to the
great shrine of itsukushima which I
noticed is part of the clip that you
play at the beginning of these
interviews as these levels of postcard
picture of a shrine gate in the water I
guess the one image that represents
Japan was directly and in this clip he
stays it and in all of a sudden another
another guest rushes out there's a big
commotion and he turns to another lodger
at the inn and ask what's going on has
somebody discovered that there are
robbers among the travelers and there's
no actually we discovered that there is
a man from southern Shikoku among us and
in southern Shikoku people will kill
children without a second thought and we
own this holy pilgrimage we can't share
roof with people who do such a thing and
so the man from southern Shikoku is so a
shame that he breaks off his pilgrimage
and goes home and vows to do better so
that's oh and I i should note in the
conversation that unfolds buttons on the
side and this in the pilgrim say well we
are from a part of japan where
certificate never happen now when a
woman is pregnant from an adulterous
affair she might seek the assistance of
an abortionist but the abortionists are
so frowned upon by the population that
even little children know that you can't
even point at their houses because
your fingers will rot off if you do and
we only suffer them to live at the edges
of the village and so on and so forth
okay so that's encounter number one
encounter number two happens at the
other end of Japan in the East right
around the same time so k 1720 and you
have a medicine peddler from a region of
Japan that again is proud to raise every
single child and this stays at this in a
part of Japan that is of a byword for
infanticide by this time the Northeast
and he sees that the innkeeper is
carrying out the the trial a newborn
child into the garden and he thinks this
odd and tags along and when he notices
that an infanticide is going to happen
he clings to his sleeves and eventually
talks him into accepting a subsidy for
buying milk in exchange for for raising
the child now both of these are stories
that are written down much later and
then so there no doubt lots of
embellishments but they were plausible
to people and the reason they were
plausible is that you had broadly
speaking three different cultures of
infanticide one is the culture that I
dedicate most of my book to a culture
that uses infanticide as the major form
of family planning and uses it to an
extent that results in the population
every generation being smaller than the
one that preceded it there is a second
area where infanticide is still evident
in the traces of the demographic record
but people don't talk much about it at
the time and it's not frequent enough to
be the cause of major depopulation in
those areas and then there's the the
final third of the archipelago where
people make it part of the identity that
they do not commit infanticide although
if you start looking into their
population registers lots of funny
things going on there too and it's it's
pretty clear that infanticide was to
some extent practice there but more
importantly they resorted to different
ways of keeping their household size
manageable and
a lot of those ways aboard people who
lived in the infanticide areas so for
example they involved selling 67 year
old daughter's into prostitution and so
the people in the Infanta seidel lands
would say you people are just like dogs
and cats how can you just sell your your
children as though they were animals we
are the true humans we raise our
children well and sure enough we have to
discard some of our kids to do so but
it's more important to raise the chosen
children well then to afflict all
children that will come with a life of
poverty and hunger and cold and bondage
in many cases okay so is it primarily a
geographic difference where these
beliefs were different would that be
true and then I guess it strikes me as
in terms of what you just said the
chosen child how were these children
chosen and then the other awful thing is
who would be the one to kill the child
lots of great questions yeah let's see
how I can do this without launching into
a long long long monologue the
geographical divisions were clearly
present in people's minds in the 18th
century 18th century is kind of the
heyday of this culture of infanticide on
the ground things were more complicated
and of course there were disagreements
some people living in areas when fanta
side was very common didn't think it was
a good idea but village communities were
fairly tight knit and if there was a
poor family that raised a fourth or
fifth trial the neighbors would come
knock come knocking at the door and ask
what are you doing what kind of
unreasonable behavior is this you'll
drive your household into ruin you're
not doing right by your own children and
by the way you'll be a welfare case for
the rest of the village so why don't you
rethink this this pregnancy and that's a
major factor for for creating this this
geological unity the other thing is that
people's attitudes to
a lot of important issues including life
death as infanticide acceptable really
depend on whom they interact with and
especially in an 18th century society
interactions are very much especially
bound so the number of people you know
who think that infanticide is a good
idea will depend very much on where you
live and so that's that's a real factor
for for this geographic pattern that we
see on the other hand there are these
disagreements and they really open up in
the 19th century when especially local
elites and the warrior governments that
that ultimately administer the villages
begin to think that infanticide is a
huge political social economic problem
and then it's a question how do these
sort of pioneers of the new view of
infant life being sacred convey that to
the in their view benighted parts of the
population you also asked how people
selected right does it matter if it was
a boy or girl I mean it did it may be
the number matter you know they went
even odd even odd I you know I have no
idea and then who was the one to take
care of that terrible task and how so
infanticide is it's quite common in the
ethnographic and historical record once
you care to look and a lot of people
know that in places like China or India
it really tended to target women or
that's at least the impression you get
from reading the documents that the
contemporary account japani was more
complicated if you were a girl you were
at a slightly higher risk of falling
victim to your parents unwillingness to
raise you but one very typical pattern
that we see very very strongly in the
demographic record is that your chances
of being accepted by your parents depend
on how many children of the same gender
already exist in the household so if
you're a girl and you're born into a
family with
two sons chances are that your parents
liked the idea of having this kind of
balance if you go born into a family
with two daughters they probably don't
need a third daughter and that that will
be it for you similarly if you're a son
and you know you're the third or the
fourth son and there's no doubt in the
household the parents might think Oh
would actually quite like our third
child to be a daughter so let's send
this child back as the phrase went and
you know not another one will come in in
a year or two or three and who took care
of sending a child back typically that's
actually a surprisingly difficult
question so we have all these accounts
and images and almost invariably it's
women who do the killing wow that is
shocking to me I would have said it was
the father or a third party that's
interesting to think about why it is it
is talking to us and I think part of
that is that we live in a world where
maternal love and and immediate maternal
love is is taken for granted but one
thing that this world that I've spent a
lot of time thinking about suggests is
that maybe this is not as as natural as
we might think much more culturally
bound and again if you if you look
around the world infanticide is so
commonly practiced in many societies
well not anymore about well actually I
was going I'm down the road I will get
to asking you at what point did it
become completely unacceptable well
maybe I should launch right into that
yes well we'll finish up with those book
the questions of who was right as always
responsible and so one thing that made
it more likely that women would do the
killing or i should say one thing that
makes it more plausible that it really
was women is that men did not lightly
enter that the birthing space childbirth
was was considered something that
was polluting you know with all the
blood being spilled and so you're quite
often it would happen even in poor
families and in a part of the house that
would be screened off sort of a separate
space and again men wouldn't usually
enter that and even in the early 20th
century a large proportion proportion of
Japanese women give birth unaided they
just squat down by themselves and
deliver the child but alas maybe their
mother-in-law will be Iran may be a
friend but often not even that I think
that's also really difficult to imagine
right from from from our current society
so there is a certain ferocious strength
to to to these women that that is in
some ways I think alien to what we
assume to be to your to be natural but
of course when you when you start
analyzing these accounts there's this
intriguing gender dimension to it you
know men trying to change the behavior
of women or denigrating women painting
women as being transmogrified into
demons into into animals and so to some
extent these accounts of women doing the
killing might be might be slightly
problematic and i don't i don't have an
ultimate answer to that in terms of who
made the decision it seems that usually
it was consensual within within the
family in in some cases that would have
been conflicts about it and you know we
have accounts of well one of the rare
cases where husband kills the child and
the wife said no this was a
misunderstanding actually wanted to
raise the child and advice of a vice
vice versa but but typically you know
that the grandparents would have a role
and and both parents in going through
the material that you sent me it looks
like literally millions of babies were
killed during this 300 year span I
imagine more in the earlier period than
moving toward the 1950s and from what
you've said today it's primarily
a survival mechanism or economic where
either the village or the family would
suffer if these children were not killed
so that gets me to the point where at
what point did it become unacceptable
and and why did that happen I should say
first that that suffering is very
relative and an Infanta side has been
studied for a long time by historians
something like 90 years and for the
first couple of decades the substandard
view was that infanticide was proof that
life was really very bad for the people
of the 18th century and that they were
always at the brink of starvation and so
on and so forth there's a little bit of
truth to that but if you look at who in
a social stratification sense practiced
infanticide their periods when the rich
seemed to do it a little bit more than
the poor and generally it's very even so
you know if you're rich person suffering
means that you can't throw a big party
for a seventh birthday of your child
then that sort of thing in right you you
you can't send presents to everybody in
the village as you're supposed to I say
you can't buy a nice new dress for your
daughter you can't send your son to
school if you if you have seven of them
but even for the poor it wasn't usually
a question of death of survival there
was this idea of what an appropriate way
of raising a child would be and that
appropriate way of raising a child
depended on your economic station and so
the fertility gnome worked out in a way
that everybody was supposed to raise two
or three children and raise them as well
as they possibly could you can look
beyond the economics of why people
committed infanticide and there were
various ideas that made infanticide seem
virtuous again a very bizarre notion to
us one of those was that well I've
mentioned several times already you have
to do right by the children you choose
to raise
so to be a good parent you commit
infanticide paradoxically another
paradox is that people who cared a lot
about their posterity about their
descendants were encouraged to commit
infanticide what mattered was the
survival of the household not the
question how many descendants you have
but that this is one prosperous
household that keeps perpetuating itself
in time and sticks around to venerate
its ancestors and the best way to ensure
the prosperity of the household is to
make sure that property doesn't have to
be divided between six sons right or
even the expenses of raising the
children detract from the strength of
the household in the future and so this
this idea of how the afterlife works
becomes entangled in the practice of
infanticide and it means that practicing
infanticide is a boon for your
descendants but also for your ancestors
who can then enjoy the continued
generation of the household and remain
and they're of Pleasant serene state of
ancestral deities as once the household
vanish vanishes those ancestors have to
go back to the cycle of rebirth and
suffering that as a big part of the
Buddhist world view so it is it is
really and one reason this this book is
getting very long it's let this is a
very complex culture that has its own
logic that I I find takes a while to to
wrap one's mind around maybe one
important piece of the puzzle though
that I that I haven't mentioned yet is
why there are in big barriers to
committing infanticide but it's one
thing to have a reason to want for your
children that was true for people in
many places and times but it's another
thing to actually take the step and kill
the child and so a real key issue is
whether you think that under any
circumstances a child can be killed and
the reason people who otherwise thought
of themselves as good at kind in the
18th century say would commit
infanticide was that
a child a newborn child was not
considered a fully formed human being
and one way we can understand that maybe
is to think about people who are well at
least in the liberal parts well let's
say that the pro-choice parts of America
have abortions they don't think of
themselves as worst parents the reason
they can have abortions is that they
don't think of fetus in the first
trimester as a fully formed human being
and where we draw the line between
something that isn't quite a human being
yet and a member of human society who
deserves the full protections that that
membership affords is arbitrary you can
say it's convenient to to draw it at
birth because that's an impressive event
with lots of noise and blood and so on
but a lot of societies actually drew it
a couple of minutes after birth at the
point when parents made the decision
whether they wanted to keep the child or
to discard the child and this is very
much the story of this culture of
infanticide in Japan that I study
getting back to the one of the questions
I had asked previously so you had said
the mother will pretty much kill the
child after giving birth is there a
special ritual that one would do as part
of this or that's a really interesting
question if anything the absence of
ritual in some ways is striking so that
it's the ritual that turns the child
into a member of the household into a
member of the human community in that
ritual would be a bath typically or
being a wrap dinner and an a rag kind of
thing there were different ways of
committing infanticide and you know some
of them involve things that seem
strangely elaborate like taking a soaked
piece of paper and putting it on the
face of the child just to suffocate the
child so maybe you can think of that as
a ritual and say well why do they go to
the trouble of soaking a piece of paper
maybe it's the idea that the child
shouldn't even draw a breath to ensure
that the child hasn't crossed this this
threshold to full human life I should
also note that this attitude to children
occurs in a society that on the whole is
is really worried about killing other
beings that's a society that puts up
stone monuments to silk worms that are
killed in sericulture monuments to our
grasshoppers that have to be killed by
pesticides so that they don't devastate
the crop it's a society that that has
elaborate burial rituals for whales that
are beached or or hunted down so that
the real story seems to be that children
are liminal at the point of birth anyway
and they can return to kind of a an
ill-defined spirit world without a great
deal of pain and in a way that isn't
really a death and because it's not
really a death killing the child isn't
really taking a life and people come up
with euphemisms that like sending back
the child or or weeding out weeding out
superfluous plants that make it I think
psychologically easier for them to
commit infanticide because there's no
doubt that it's still unpleasant for
people that nobody nobody likes doing
this but you need a lot of of cultural
justifications for committing and fanta
side and a lot of incentives for doing
it as well okay and your book goes to
1950 were there still infanticides
taking place at that time and and did
you study the period you know after that
when did it officially end or was
outlawed or is it outlawed at this point
I I assume it is oh yes very much
yes so that the situation of infanticide
in Japan today is the same as in the
United States really it happens rarely
when it happens people are shocked about
let's see 30 or 40 years ago there was a
series of babies abandoned in coin
lockers and people found it very
shocking and thought it said something
profound and disturbing about the state
of their society which in itself is
interesting because you know some of the
people who lived in a world where
infanticide was something to be
encouraged we're still alive at this
time so it gives you a sense of the
magnitude of the social change the
single most surprising discovery for me
and this project actually was that
infanticide still occurred on a huge
scale in the early 20th century when i
submitted my dissertation the first
version of this project i thought i had
it all figured out and the ark was that
by the 1880s which is the time when
people stop talking about infanticide it
also went went away as a phenomenon and
there's there's a break in the
demographic record right after 1870 and
so we can't perform the kind of analyses
that d the early material allows in the
modern period which which is rather
ironic but the modern period has another
type of data that in some ways is just
as valuable and those are statistics
about stillbirths and still with are
fairly consistent in different societies
when you look at all the statistics that
have been collected in 19th century
europe and 20th century developing world
and so on and it's very rare for a slow
birth rate to go over four percent in
japan their districts where was more
than forty percent I mean I was calling
yes they were calling thee they're just
using a different word for the
infanticide being stillbirth exactly
because they had to report it to the
authorities and in an individual case
it's very hard to tell right into you
you only noticed that there's a huge
with cover-up going on when you look at
the statistics and and look at them in
space because when you add it up for all
of Japan that the rate is only seven
percent and so I say oh well maybe
health conditions like syphilis drove it
up but when you see that there are these
of clusters where almost every second
trial is claimed to be stillborn you you
notice that something funny as is going
on now this is still very much the
situation around 1900 but then in the
1920s the the still birth rates begin to
fall rapidly and and so our estimates
for the number of infanticides really go
down from depending on where you see the
balance between later of abortions and
infanticides tens of thousands or more
than 100,000 and they at the beginning
of the 20th century to just a couple of
thousand in the late 30s and then
because of the the great east asian and
pacific war there's a there's another
break in the statistics and we don't
really know what's going on during the
war they stopped because the statistics
just just aren't there after the war i
found 11 report of a woman remembering
her life that that mentions and
infanticide in 1945 but this this would
have been in a fairly exceptional
occurrence as my son's and then in in
1948 1949 abortion is effectively
legalized in Japan I say and you got
this huge surge in abortion there are
somewhere between a million and three
million abortions depending on how many
you think were really reported by the
mid-1950s and abortion for this brief
moment in time becomes the main way that
Japanese couples plan their their
families and then contraceptive practice
slowly gradually take takes over but
once safe abortion is available
there's just no more need to to commit
infanticide and also the fact that the
rates already declined so much in the
1920s suggests that there's something
very in Congress about living in a world
of electricity and you know being being
a citizen of a civilizing empire that
has so much civilization that it can
share it with the less fortunate parts
of Asia whether they want it or not on
the one hand and committing infanticide
on the other hand so there might also be
a generational story that not the 1920s
the women were in their 40s and have
that their last children they might
still think infanticide is culturally
acceptable but their daughters who have
usually had a primary school education
at least and too much more part of this
this new world do not see this way a lot
of open questions for me especially in
this twentieth century part I hope
somebody else will we'll pick it up in
the years ahead and look more more
deeply into this but at present that's
that's my best guess off of the dynamics
that lead to to the terminal retreat of
infanticide from Japan okay very good
thank you so much for being here with us
today and sharing some of your work well
I enjoyed it as you can tell thank you
very much for more information about
professor Drexler and his research
please visit our website at yale edu
backslash macmillan report be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale